that being said can you give us an
example of a film that is driven by
story and that that is driven by
character
no because character is story as I said
before what is a character rather than
what she does and what she says okay I
have a friend who is a TV writer and he
has a partner a writing partner they
collaborate and so he told me that
somebody said to them oh you guys work
to get so like you do the character and
he does the story as if you could do
that separately characters don't exist
outside of stories they exist only
inside of stories again they are what
they like Hamlet they are what they do
and what they say so you can when people
talk about a character-driven movie they
just mean a good movie okay how about
plot driven but let me just point out to
you how many movies and plays and great
classics are just the name of the
protagonist of the main character for
example Hamlet here Macbeth Romeo Juliet
Julius Caesar
that's just how about go back to the
Greeks Medea Oedipus look at the great
movies The Godfather Citizen Kane it's
not always that way but more often than
not it is the name of the character that
is the also the name of the movie the
name of the protagonist and I only
mentioned it in this context because I'm
trying to indicate to you that you can't
separate story and character which is
more important it's like asking somebody
what's more important to you your heart
or your lungs well what about plot maybe
plot is your appendix which you could
have removed what is it is to me again
there's a lot of jargon attached to all
of all of this I do a lot of expert
witnessing I am a court authorized
expert in intellectual property issues
legal issues mainly plagiarism and cop
an infringement and I don't mind telling
you this few experiences that mellow the
spirits better than meeting with a bunch
of lawyers and having them pay you money
a much more agreeable dynamic these
cases are always fascinating
sometimes in the law they refer to
separately to plot and something they
call sequence of events but to me plot
and sequence is the sequence of events
is the story plot sequence of events
story visa synonyms lease in in lay
terms you know just just and it's the
most important thing and the hardest the
most difficult the most elusive thing to
achieve is a good story I could paint
for you a word picture of a wacky crazy
kind of a character and there's there
were workshops that actually do this you
just invent characters and you talk
about what kind of a tree she would be
if she were a tree and what kind of
candy bar she would eat if she ate a
candy bar and all of these and people
feel all kind of creators they create
these things but it's nonsense I think
it's actually anti useful because it
suggests that characters exist outside
of stories what I want to hear is when
students pitch their stories in my
classes they're orally telling the story
to me and the eight writers around the
table including themselves what I want
to hear is what do we see and what are
we here I don't want to hear that Harry
enters he's had a job years ago when he
worked there they never got along with
his mother he's the kind of guy who does
it but please just tell me I mean how is
the audience sitting in the movie
theater going to get that they're gonna
get that from what they see and what
they hear nobody's gonna be sitting next
to them whispering in their area let me
pay about this part that's coming up
what I was trying to do here so that's
what I want to hear in the class from
the writers we see this we hear that and
that's what readers for agents and for
production companies want to see on the
page we see this we hear that that's all
there is and everything else has to come
out of that
you